hello my name is magnus walker and i was
born in
1967 in sheffield england
i left school at 15 and i came to
america
at the age of 19. well eight weeks ago
i didn't know what a ted talk was and to
be honest i'm not quite sure why i'm
here today
but i do appreciate the opportunity to
be with you guys
and share my story my journey and my
hopes and my dreams
you know i having left school at 15 you
know for me
i didn't really have any future well i
came to america
28 years ago and that represented the
land of opportunity
for me and in those past 28 years i've
been able to build
three things a successful clothing
company
a film location business and also
a restored race driven and collected
quite a lot of classic
porsches now porsche is a passion for me
and i'll talk about that in detail in a
little bit but all three of those things
share one common bond
i had no education in them i didn't
really think i was going to end up in
that particular field
i didn't really know where i was going
but all three of those things have a
common thread
a common bond and that common bond for
me really
was freedom freedom to do whatever i
wanted to do
and a dream sort of to be able to
i suppose uh live my life to the fullest
and do whatever i wanted to do
so coming to america really was a
journey
and i'll start my journey in 1977.
1977 in england was sort of a special
year
we had this uh punk rock thing going on
and we also had this world jubilee thing
going on
but for me it was the start of a very
memorable moment
my father took me to the london roles
court motor show in 1977
and back then i fell in love with this
car was a white martini porsche
now any kid growing up anywhere in the
world in the late 70s early 80s
chances are you probably had a choice of
three cars on your wall
porsche turbo ferrari boxer or
lamborghini countach
for some reason i chose porsche i even
wrote a letter to porsche when i was 10
years old
and essentially said to him hey i want
to design for porsche and they wrote
back to me and said well
callers when you're a little bit older
which i thought was pretty funny and
they sent me a sales brochure and uh
35 years later they'd end up writing me
a letter back but i'll get to that story
a little bit later on
so i'm this young kid growing up in
sheffield sheffield's a grim northern
steel town as shown by this picture
right here
you know and there wasn't necessarily
many porsches on the road
so i filed that dream away i had the
poster on the wall
and i was watching motorsports as a kid
also in 1977
england had james hunt he was a formula
one world champion
and we also had barry sheen he was a
two-wheel motogp
champion back then so even though i
didn't grow up with any sort of fancy
cars
my father was a salesman i grew up in a
working class background
i did have this dream early on and
somehow this dream
involved porsche i also
back then was a pretty competitive
middle distance cross-country runner
sort of a solo sport guy and i used to
love getting out there and running
i became quite competitive i joined this
club called the halamsha harriers and
yeah this guy called sebastian co set
quite a few world records and
ran at the 80 and 84 olympic games and
he was sort of inspirational to me
around that same same time i also fell
in love with something called
heavy metal music now growing up in
sheffield there are a lot of rock bands
you know it may have been sort of a
slightly depressed uh grim northern city
but there was a lot of music and a lot
of fun
so i fell in love with porsche doing
some middle distance cross-country
running
fell in love with heavy metal music and
i decided at the end of the
fifth year i would leave school i left
school in 1982
basically with 200 levels and no real
future
by that time i'd also figured out i
could go drink in a pub so
for some reason that was great for going
to clubs and having fun but wasn't so
good for being a middle distance
cross-country runner and an athlete
so that sort of faded away but there was
a little thing that stuck with me was
the passion
and sort of the drive and i think to
this day
those memorable moments earlier on are
still with me i'm still running around
i'm still
chasing around and i'm still running
after my goal
so i bummed around on the dole for a
little bit
doing odd jobs and stuff like that and i
started to hear this comment quite a lot
cut your hair and get a real job well i
was on the dole working construction
living at home no car taking the bus
places
and for a year or two that was okay by
the time i turned 17 though i decided
okay
i'm not going to cut my hair but maybe i
should think about getting a job
so i actually took a year-long leisure
and recreation study course sports
management at a college
and i heard about this thing called camp
america well what was camp america i
didn't know but apparently camp america
sent kids to work on a summer camp in
the united states of america
now growing up as a kid of course i
watched a lot of american tv
most of the shows i loved centered
around action and cars starsky and herch
dukes a hazard chip
so i had this american dream it involved
evil knievel and uh
anyway long story short i took this leap
of faith and i applied
to camp america it was a little bit of a
strange feeling and
i've had these strange feelings in the
past and somehow when my gut
tells me to do something generally it's
a good thing hence
go on you gut feeling so by pure luck i
suppose i was accepted into camp america
got on a flight to new york took a
trailways bus from new york
that's the bus i took to detroit now
detroit was great it was sort of similar
to sheffield
former industrial city also happened to
be the sort of
automotive hub of the united states but
i wasn't in detroit i was
30 minutes north on a summer camp
working with inner city underprivileged
kids
that happened to be from detroit now
that was a big culture shock for me
because you know i'm this heavy metal
guy from sheffield north of england i'm
sort of in the middle of nowhere
i had to adapt pretty quickly so i
adapted pretty quickly on this summer
camp and when that camp was over
i got back on that trailways bus and i
took that bus
out west landed in los angeles 1986
union station 4 am in the morning you
know
i'd watched all those tv shows but i
found myself being awakened on a park
bench at 6 am in the morning by a lapd
guy who told me you can't sleep here and
i was sort of a little bit disappointed
i'd seen all these shows in and around
l.a but where are all the beautiful
people where all the rock stars and
movie stars
that wasn't happening in downtown l.a
but quickly i found my way to hollywood
and
over the next couple of years you know i
sort of did a few odd jobs but there was
one pivotal moment that happened within
three days of being in los angeles
found myself at this ymca hotel right
off hollywood boulevard
i went shopping on hollywood boulevard
and i saw these great pvc
alligator print pants that were on sale
for 9.99 so
i bought myself a pair but they didn't
really fit good so i went back to the
youth hostel bought a sewing kit and
sewed them inside out and
decided i'm going to go to this street
that everyone was talking about called
melrose so i ended up going down there
to melrose and
walked into this shop that was called
retail slot was a punk rock shop and
there was a guy working there that was
in
a band called faster pussycat his name
was tami
pivotal part to a story here tammy says
to me uh realized i was from england
struck up a conversation and said
where'd you get those pants from
i said hey you know i got them from
england i had to think quick on my feet
i said why do you want to buy him just
sort of jokingly and he said sure
yeah how much are they so at this point
i hadn't thought about selling these
pants but i said
first number that came to mind 25 bucks
he said okay i'll take eight pairs so i
ran right up to hollywood boulevard
bought eight pairs of pants went back
down sold him to him fifteen dollars
profit per pen
i realized in that one hour transaction
i'd made more straight away
in what literally within being in la for
three days and i'd made in a whole week
work in construction in england
so i thought oh maybe la's the place for
me seems pretty easy
they speak english a lot of rock and
roll it was guns and roses motley crew
it was a great time over the next few
years
fast forward to 1989 i'm selling
secondhand clothing on the boardwalk in
venice going to yard sales buying
old levi's cowboy boots western shirts
i'm in the clothing industry now
venice beach back then was a major
tourist attraction a lot of european
people coming through
and little by little this grew into a
business which became known as serious
clothing and we ended up outfitting
everyone from alice cooper to madonna
and everyone in between we started
wholesaling a
small chain called hot topic back then
hot topic had five stores and would grow
to
over 500 stores so we sort of went from
making a little amount of clothing to
making thousands of pieces of clothing
well in 1994 we realized being in venice
wasn't so easy for a clothing company we
moved downtown and rented a
loft in a warehouse for the next six
years serious clothing then started
doing a lot of music videos and also a
lot of
um outfits for magazines and stylists
were calling all the time
serious clothing had its own unique
style we took fabrics that were
not necessarily garment fabrics we used
some car seat fabrics and made them into
jackets and things like that
non-conventional materials thinking
outside the box
and basically doing what we like to wear
well by 2000 we realized we'd paid two
people's mortgages and we needed
hey let's buy our own building so we
ended up finding this building oh that
was me back then forgot that little
picture
so that was me pre-beard that sort of
circa 1994.
sirius was one of the top 10 clothing
companies to watch
so anyway 2000 my wife karen found this
building in the arts district
people said you're crazy no one wants to
be there form a desolate industrial area
well long story short we took another
leap of faith it felt good in our gut
feeling why are we buying two
paying two people's mortgages when we
could own our own building
so we bought that building about a year
later right after 9 11 in 2001 there was
an article in the la times about life
gentrification
we got a phone call would we be
interested in renting the building for a
music video
bang before you know it we're in the
film location business
well hey we've been filming since night
uh since 2001 over 100 days a year
doing things from low budget still
shoots to big budget movies and
over uh a dozen reality shows like
america's next top model
so we've met a lot of interesting people
but we didn't plan to build a film
location we were building our dream
live work house where we lived upstairs
and operated our clothing company out of
downstairs
so we'd accidentally fallen into another
somewhat lucrative business
this is la it's a movie town we've met
quite a lot of interesting people they
always say how did you get here
well we tell them we followed our gut
feeling so remember that little story as
a 10 year old when i fell in love with
porsche
so i fell in love with porsche as a 10
year old
i didn't buy my first porsche until
1992. serious clothing had become quite
successful and from 92 to 2000
i was racing around getting quite a lot
of speeding tickets 2001
i took my aggressive street driving to
the track and joined the porsche owners
club
i went through their program learned
learned how to do cup racing
instructing and for the next five years
was doing 50 track days a year
turn around to probably 2008 2009
i'd spent a lot of money racing and
decided okay my next passion
i love these cars why don't i try and
restore a few of them
well i didn't have no mechanical
background but i had passion i often
talk about passion goes a long long way
you know if you've got the will and the
desire and put the motivation
in and are focused things tend to happen
also a little bit of luck and a leap of
faith really helps out as well
but i asked a lot of questions and i
started uh restoring a couple of cars
so i got a little bit of interest in
european car magazines and i started
this blog online well there's a thread
on this
porsche forum called pelican parts and i
called my blog porsche collection out of
control hobby
and it was sort of like a catch-all of
what i was doing
and so this was sort of going to become
a pivotal point where it was like
something i really really enjoyed to do
and i'd start restoring these cars well
about two years ago
a pivotal moment in our life happened
again we've seem to have had these every
10 years these
pivotal moments that seem to happen by
accident
or they're just naturally evolving we
never had this
5-10 year planned business model always
go back to
follow your gut do what you love to do
so
i haven't been in the film industry
we've got quite a lot of people
interested in
making little tv shows and stuff like
that but we weren't quite ready for the
exposure or the cam
compatibility wasn't quite right or it
just didn't click
so i got a call from this canadian
called tamir moscovici well he'd seen a
couple of articles and he was a film
director
also a porsche guy and he was looking
for something edgy for his reel he was
sort of sick of doing bud light
commercials and figured hey
maybe there's more to magnus's story
than meets the eye so we had a couple of
conversations and
uh tamir ended up flying down to l.a a
little over two years ago on his
frequent flyer miles complete leap of
faith
his original idea was to make a short
youtube documentary
well our goal was what's the worst that
could happen here we're gonna
drive around race around in my favorite
porsches for four days and maybe get
some good footage out of it
well what turned out to be a 32 minute
uh documentary was shot over four days
so we shot it i think in february of
2012 and we released a trailer in
june of 2012. that first day we didn't
know what would happen with the trailer
but somehow it got picked up by top gear
and within the first day it got
over 50 000 views and all of a sudden i
just found this thing called facebook i
figured maybe i should get on that i
didn't really know much about it
so anyway i got on facebook and this
time i don't even have an iphone so i'm
not really
internet savvy but all of a sudden i
keep getting all these friend requests
from all these oddball places
you know spain and uh indonesia and i'm
thinking what's going on well
this trailer for the three-minute film
urban outlaw that top gear picked up had
got blocked and reblogged and reblogged
well this was pretty exciting so this
was a leap of faith project everyone was
sort of working on a shoestring budget
bro down buddy favorite type of thing
and they were doing this sort of on the
side so you know little by little i
started posting the film was going to
come out well to me being sort of a
production type of guy he shopped it
around a few
film festivals well somehow it got into
this thing called the rain dance film
festival which i described as the rainy
version
of sundance that's in england so well
i'm from england what are the chances
that you get to premiere your film
uh in front of an audience similar to
this so karen and i flew to london and
we premiered the film in
piccadilly circus on a saturday night
around 10 o'clock and it sold out there
was a buzz about this film
well we decided okay we're going to
release it online so october 15th the
film went online and probably two weeks
after it came out i got a phone call
from
jay leno jay leno had seen the film and
wanted to be on his garage show
well that started the avalanche of what
has happened for the past 18 months
all of a sudden is my life before urban
outlaw came out and is my life after
now at this point we've been doing
serious clothing for 20 years
and we weren't quite as motivated as we
once were you know we
always said we designed what we
personally like to wear but over the
past few years we've sort of been
treading water
so we took this leap of faith and
decided success
really is the freedom to do whatever you
want to do so we decided we were going
to close sirius down
this was the baby that had enabled us to
get to this point
now it wasn't like we gave up on sirius
we still had all the patterns and the
samples
but what it did was once we decided to
pull that band-aid off
it allowed us some breathing room we
didn't know what was coming next but we
sort of knew
it was going to be something pretty good
so once we closed that door
probably in the past 18 months i've
probably done a hundred
magazine video tv show interviews and it
really i think by closing
sirius's door it opened up all this
freedom to travel
well you remember me telling you about
porsche and that letter i wrote was a
ten-year-old
well about a month after the film came
out i received a letter from porsche
basically they'd seen the film and
was sort of impressed with my porsche
passion and uh realized he'd written me
a letter 35 years later
and ironically in the film tamir asked
me what do you think porsha would think
about you doing
i said i don't know but i hope they'd be
smiling and i hope they'd be happy
so porsha wrote me a second letter i
wish i still had the first one but i do
have the second one
they invited me to go visit them and uh
stuck garden tour the museum which i
went to do and
purely by coincidence ended up being
there on 9 11 2013.
well after that there was the l.a auto
show and we did a couple of events with
porsche hosted these events at our
garage in downtown l.a
it was a worldwide dealer event they
brought all their dealers over
and incorporated me into this workshop
where porsche was talking about what
porsche does
restoration and porsche classic and i
think they sensed i have this thing
a porsche passion is what i said it was
and it's something that you can't really
build and you can't market and you can't
sell it's just sort of there
so from them porsche integrated me into
this workshop invited me out to an event
in essen germany
and basically uh i started to invite me
out to places and incorporate me into
their commercials coming up
so the porsche connection was quite
simple but what we hadn't expected that
also came from the film
was we got approached by nike we got
approached by oakley and then we had a
visit from
bentley's chief of designer and we also
had a visit from uh
bmw and volvo and it's almost like these
people were coming down thinking i was
some sort of focus group and they're
asking my opinion
on what did i think about certain things
i'm scratching my head a little bit
thinking well
i'm just a guy doing my own thing but
you know people seem to have responded
to it well i get a lot of emails from
people who talk often about you know the
video and the greatest thing i suppose
separated people like in the cars
is the fact that people found the film
and my story
inspirational so if there's one message
i can leave you with
you know for me what i've done over the
past 28 years involved a lot of leap of
faith
always going on my gut feeling when
things sort of seemed awkward that was
often the case to know
hey we're on the right track here and
just stay motivated stay dedicated
we never asked anyone's opinion we just
did what we like to do
and it sort of seems to have worked out
quite nice for us now we don't know
where we're going i often say i'm on
this open road
along for the ride so we'll see what
comes next but i really appreciate all
your time and allow me to share my story
and cheers and all the best